I don't see it trainers day where
everyone see tell me the news tell me
hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is my
breakdown for Sherlock series 3 episode
1 empty hurts that I've been promising
you guys for the last couple of days
what I did is just watch the episode
many many times to just try and find as
many references as possible and you know
facts about behind the scenes production
so this will be just a little bit
different from my normal Easter Egg
videos if you haven't been following me
on social easier I've been talking about
anime club today so there's a bunch of
other stuff going on this weekend in
addition to episode 2 airing tomorrow
I'll be posting my review for that right
up to the episode error so be sure to
subscribe to get it so since this
breakdown has really specific details
about the plot and what goes on during
empty hearse consider it super spoilery
so careful if you haven't watched the
episode yet so here we go blowing the
doors off the empty hearse number 1 the
title is a reference to the Conan Doyle
story the empty house both this episode
and that book brought the character back
from the dead so to speak
Doyle killed the character in his novel
the final problem the character was so
popular that fans and his publisher
compelled him to bring the character
back which led to the aventures of the
empty house so if anyone didn't like
that there was so much fanservice in
episode 1 remember that Conan Doyle's
novel empty house was essentially
written as fanservice to Sherlock Liv's
theories we don't learn that what we're
seeing is Anderson's theory until the
last frame cuts after his first scenario
let me know below in the comments how
long it took you to figure it out I
didn't realize until the Molly kiss but
the weird dance track made me very
suspicious plus there's the fact that
Darren Brown is actually a famous
real-life hypnotist Sherlock tells
Watson later that there are 13
possibilities of how he could survive
there's a big debate going on in the
fandom as to whether he meant 13 ways he
could have faked his death or just 13
ways that he could have escaped Moriarty
most of those theories presume that he
never suspected Moriarty would be so
committed to his plan that he'd kill
himself in order to force Sherlock's
hand all of the scenarios were filmed in
broad daylight with a full crowd of
reporters and people watching and no one
leaked any of the information but there
were a few pictures that made it to
tumblr number 3 Moriarty returns Andrew
Scott who plays Moriarty appears in all
the rooftop scenarios all those scenes
were filmed during series 3 production
meaning that he came back on set early
on people leaked that he would be part
of the new episodes kind of misleading
people into thinking that he did not die
on top of the
later we learned that he did in fact die
from that gunshot wound but people keep
asking me what happened to his body
because Sherlock and Mycroft were one
step ahead of Moriarty the whole time
they basically had a government crew
ready to take the body into custody
number four
Mycroft knew the whole time after
Lestrade calls Anderson on his crackpot
theory the press montage lets us know
that everyone ended up learning the real
truth about what Maury already did
because Sherlock and Mycroft wanted to
stay one step ahead of Moriarty they let
him discredit Sherlock
so whenever Sherlock finished getting
rid of Moriarty's terror network there
was no more reason to keep up the
deception which is why the press are
just now figuring out the truth number
five
mustache watch begins we see Watson with
the caterpillar on his lip and Mary
Morstan
Freeman was actually on loan to Steven
Moffat and Mark Gatiss for six weeks to
film the first two episodes this is just
because filming on Sherlock series 3
started while production on The Hobbit
was still going on and Martin Freeman
was still under contract to Peter
Jackson the moustache as well as other
people's facial hair like Anderson's is
just a sign that they've let themselves
go since they believed Sherlock has been
dead the last two years
Watson even explains to mrs. Hudson that
he never called her just because he let
a lot of things slide
mostly shaving his upper lip number 6
Mary Morstan Mary's played by Amanda
Abbington Martin Freeman's real-life
partner if you haven't seen them
together they're pretty adorable number
7 Sherlock on the cross the Russian
based Sherlock got caught breaking into
was the last place he went to dismantle
Moriarty's terror cell as a character
he's kind of repressed emotionally
because he's been on his own for this
past two years number 8 Mycroft in the
field the Mycroft character in the books
is much more isolated than Mark Davis's
version so even though he complains
about having to go in the field to save
Sherlock it's actually a huge deal that
his character did that you learned later
that Mycroft is actually much smarter
than Sherlock and that when they were
growing up
Sherlock thought he was stupid by
comparison that is until they met other
children and Sherlock realized that they
were very very different you can think
of Mycroft and Sherlock like a sliding
scale of weirdness and intellect so
Sherlock is brilliant but he can coexist
with other human beings Mycroft is a
genius and totally can't stand people
number 9 back to London the terror plot
that brings Sherlock back to London got
a lot of complaints from fans Mark
Gatiss used the Sebastian Moran
character as part of that tube bomb plot
in the episode the character kinda gets
pushed to the side in the novels
Sebastian Moran is like an evil version
of Watson they both served in the
military but Sebastian met Moriarty
instead of meeting Sherlock so imagine
what would have happened to Watson if
after he left Afghanistan he would have
met Moriarty first instead of meeting
Sherlock there's a really interesting
parallel in the relationship between
Moran and Moriarty and the relationship
between Sherlock and Watson but that
doesn't really come across during this
episode a lot of people actually confuse
Molly's fiance with the sniper from
Reichenbach Fall that sniper was
actually an homage to the Moran
character from the novels but in episode
1 the Moran character is a government
official
Sherlock also calls Moran the head rat
that's actually a reference to the
Holmes adventure that was talked about
but never happened in the books it's
called the giant rat of Sumatra it's
also a street in your bowl and bush in
West Hampstead for which platforms and
staircases were built but no
above-ground entry number 10 the tube is
wonky a lot of people noticed that the
plotting in the maps of the London Tube
were all wrong this was actually done on
purpose the maps of the tube are heavily
copyrighted and no one has ever allowed
to use them in film or TV number 11
mustache references I know I promised to
try and count all the moustache jokes I
counted about 20 total over the course
of the episode there was a group of
three then another group of three and a
group of seven and then a group of six
so they all happened in spurts
number 12 John Locke for the win when
Watson tells mrs. Hudson that he's
getting engaged she genuinely thought
that he and Sherlock had been a couple
that whole time they were together which
is hilarious it also pays homage to the
subtext that the fandom has always
really read into those characters number
13 the upturned collar the first time
Sherlock puts the jacket back on is the
first time the game is on theme stirs it
doesn't play in full until he re-enters
Baker Street much to the screams of mrs.
Hudson number 14 the reunion
Sherlock disguises himself trying to
find a clever way to let Watson know
that he's still alive this is a joke
about the characters master of disguise
persona the real joke is that Watson
doesn't even notice in the first notice
the three diamonds on Watson's
engagement ring there are subtle
reference to the Three's Company
situation of their characters as well as
the wedding episode the sign of three
that's coming next it's almost as if
Mary will
be marrying Watson and Sherlock or
marrying Watson and gaining a Sherlock
later in the episode whenever Watson
tries to rip the beard off a patient
it's also a reference to the Holmes
character in the novel's the titles of
the DVDs that the character in the
episode tries to give to Watson are the
same titles of the books that the
original Holmes character tried to sell
to Watson number 15 the head but Watson
attacked Sherlock with a headbutt in one
of the progressively dirtier restaurants
that they get thrown out of in the
original story
Watson fainted when Holmes reappeared 16
Mary is a liar
Sherlock deduces Mary and sees that
she's a liar there's a lot of theories
but most of this will tie in with
episode 2 the sign of three when you see
Mary talking to Sherlock later in the
episode you see the date reference for
May 11 2013 later in the episode Mary
mentions that her wedding to Watson is
in May meaning that she is definitely
tied up with a villain but that does not
necessarily make her an evil character
number 17 London is a cesspool
Sherlock's voice over speech is taken
directly from something Watson wrote
during the original book story Study in
Scarlet number 18
Doctor Who references notice that the
round things on the wallpaper of mr.
Schill COTS apartment resembled the
round things of the TARDIS then there's
the code name of Sherlock and Mycroft's
plan Lazarus that's the same name of an
episode of Doctor Who that mark a -
wrote and started and then there's the
TARDIS on Anderson's wall number 19
remember remember the 5th of November
this is a reference to Guy Fawkes Day
who was remembered for the Gunpowder
Plot of 1605 which served as inspiration
for the tube bomb plot number 20
Sherlock's parents a lot of people
recognize that Sherlock's parents are
Benedict Cumberbatch's real-life parents
but did you notice that the collar on
his mother's coat is turned up meaning
that Sherlock got his trademark upturned
collar from his mother Sherlock Holmes
what a mama's boy number 21 the final
explanation Mark Gatiss explained that
even though this wasn't completely
correct it was the most plausible
explanation for how Sherlock survived
the fall since I'm sure there are a ton
of references that you guys may have
caught that I might have missed be sure
to write them in the comments if he
didn't see them in my video I'll be
posting my review of episode 2 the sign
of 3 right up to the episode airs
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get it
I'll also be taking questions
the comments they included my Q&A video
for Monday - so if you want me to answer
one of your questions in a Q&A video
just write it in the comments for my
review of sine of three a couple days
after that I'll also post a breakdown
video just like this right now click
here to get my Q&A for empty Hertz and
click here to get my review of the
episode thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight high fives
[Music]
you